all right uh thanks for the introduction
um we're trying to build NLP products
not only for nip developers at Deep set
but everywhere basically
um and today I'll be talking about
building a personal assistant with
Haystack and GPT and more specifically I
want to focus on how to feed facts to
large language models and how to reduce
hallucinations
um just a few words about myself I'm not
as
um I work as a lead product manager at
Deep set I've been an NLP engineer
before
I live in Berlin and when I'm not
working on NLP products I like to climb
normally I deep set I work on our
commercial product deep site Cloud but
this is not what I'm talking about today
today I'll be talking about
Haystack what is Haystack
um Haystack is an open source framework
some of you might know it it's pretty
much targeted at pragmatic developers
who want to build production grade
applications with large language models
and as such it comes pretty much with
batteries included so it provides a vast
range of file and document converters
pre-processing Vector databases
such as Pinecone or elasticsearch or
quadrant you can use embedding or hybrid
retrieval and then you can of course
connect to many different models you can
use open source models everything on the
on the hugging face hub for example but
you can also use commercial large
language models like
open AIS models or cohes models
and you can use these for pretty much
any NLP task so one of them which is
pretty buzzwordy right now definitely
generative AI but you can also do more
classical things like extractive
question answering named entity
recognition classification like
everything wrapped into kind of a neat
pipeline abstraction that lets you build
an NLP application from end to end with
everything you need
all right and what are we building today
so I really wanted to walk you through
this end-to-end building experience
today as well so what we are building is
a kind of personal knowledge assistant
that can answer questions about Haystack
and it also helps you write Haystack
code and we're doing that with Haystack
and then on the model side we'll be
using GPT in two variants
all right
so when you come to that
um
aim of building a personal assistant
with large language models I don't know
who of you has maybe played with chat
GPT probably everyone and you saw maybe
also the examples where it
was pretty impressive but then it didn't
exactly do what he wanted it to do and
some of the problems you might face when
you want to use chat GPT or gpt3 or gpt4
for something that is actually useful
are hallucinations outdated knowledge
and also kind of running it on your own
data
and I'm gonna talk about each of these
problems very briefly and then we jump
into how to tackle them all at once
all right
hallucinations what is a hallucination
um a very simple definition would be
when a language model makes things up we
call that hallucination so generally
these are responses from large language
models where it generates some text that
isn't really true maybe
maybe it even hasn't ever seen exactly
that text and its training data and it's
just not the answer to your question
maybe as well so it hallucinates
something
which you really don't want when you
want to put these models into production
an example of that
is here I'm asking chat gvt to code with
Haystack I'm not entirely sure if that's
readable but briefly on the left hand
side
I'm asking it to generate Haystack code
actually
and it should just initialize the prompt
node with us which is our kind of
abstraction layer around large language
models where you can use them
interchange in the interchangeably and
it generates some code for me so I can
see I'm asking okay please initialize
the prompt node with an open AI model
and I see it gets an API key from openai
it defines a model engine with text
DaVinci 2 that's not not the most recent
model but it's a fine choice so why not
and then it also
creates a prompt for me here asks a
question about a topic and get an answer
and then it initializes a prompt node
passing model prompt and Max sequence
length of 512 to that node and that
actually looks kind of plausible it even
explains the code below um foreign
but
this code will never run because it's
completely made up
so on the right hand side you see a
snippet from our documentation using
chat GPT with the prompt node and as you
see the the differences are minor but
you need to pass a model name or path to
the model to The Prompt node you
directly need to pass the API key next
sequence length doesn't exist and that's
interesting as well because 512 is kind
of has always been the canonical Max
sequence length for Transformers but
actually open AI models they don't have
that limitation it's more like eight
thousand thirty two thousand so that's
not true at all and it's probably
something it just has seen very often in
its training data
yeah so
this basically is what we call a
hallucination
um next problem outdated knowledge
um you've probably all seen this
response from chat GPT like as a large
language model trained by open AI blah
blah blah my cut-off date is in
September 2021 which means that without
modifications this llm will only make
predictions or can only like give you
information let's say
that actually have been part of its
original training data so whenever
you're kind of prompting the model for
its own knowledge for its World
Knowledge I don't know ask who the
president of some country is or whatever
it might give you information back but
unless
it hasn't changed like that information
um might be just like outdated and one
example of that might be I'm actually
um going to to python us uh tomorrow and
so I asked like where's python us this
year and it says it's in Pittsburgh
Pennsylvania and then that's interesting
it's like from May 1st until May 9th
2020 so you can already see that chat
GPT doesn't really have a notion of what
year we are in it doesn't know it's 2023
and I actually checked and pycon in 2020
was supposed to be in Pittsburgh
Pennsylvania but then there was this
other thing that happened in 2020
which made pretty much any com
conference impossible to to take place
in person and that was covered and in a
small screenshot there you can see that
pycon 2020 will be happening online and
it was happening online and not in
Pittsburgh so
you can see that somehow GPT had in its
training data that pycon us 2020 will be
in Pittsburgh Pennsylvania not in May by
the way in April but it kind of got half
of it correct until things changed
um and this will be happening very often
whenever you run such a model in
production you cannot really update it
in a way that
um you kind of give the new knowledge
via training into its parameters that
doesn't really work it's not really
feasible it would be very costly so you
will need to find some other strategy
and then
um the next problem
you might want the model to run on your
own data
and why would you want to do that let's
say you work at some company you have
some obscure internal framework that you
developed and you also have some
documentation but of course that's not
public and if you're a developer and you
want to kind of make a QA system on that
documentation you will need to give that
documentation to GPT somehow and of
course there's one aspect is this whole
like privacy and actually keeping
corporate secret secret thing I'm not
covering that here but you definitely if
you want to give that data to open AI
you need to find some way to add that
data at inference time basically
and
here's an example of chat GPT not having
access
to any internal data so here I'm asking
chair GPT what one of our company values
is deep sets company values and it gives
me something that might be the company
value of any
generic startup out there but it's
actually not one of ours so it's not
like the value
it gave me back as an answer here
instead one of our values is make other
shine always go the extra mile for the
open source community and have every
everyone basically achieve their goals
and try to make them shine and of course
GPT cannot know that because that's only
in our internal
knowledge base basically so there's no
way that this answer could be correct
unless we have generic values that every
startup has then yes maybe
um
all right so how can you actually
solve these problems one way to tackle
all of these problems is
what used to be called retrieval
augmented generation as a concept that
has been around at least for like two or
three years I don't know
um and basically what you do is you give
um
GPT access to some other external
knowledge base
and here's how that might look like so
that's a bit complex but I'm going to
break it down for you so
um rag that's retrieval augmented
generation and what you see here at the
top is a query that I want to feed into
the system so how will Google actually
change its search strategy to beat its
emerging competition
emerging from the from the current wave
of generative AI something that people
at Google might be asking themselves and
of course
if we would just ask for that it would
make something up or it would say I
don't have any knowledge of recent
events something like that
um so what we do is we run that query
against a database of knowledge
that we collected beforehand so here I'm
running on let's say news articles and I
actually asked that question and I get
back the most relevant documents and
what we call this is the retrieval step
so you can use a retriever a search
component which actually gets four
question relevant data from a knowledge
base so classic search basically
you can have that in different
complexities you can use Simple keyword
search you can use something like TF IDF
or bm25 but of course you can also use
other language models and convert your
query to into vectors and then use
Vector embedding search so this database
then would be a vector database and then
what you do is
in the prompt for GPT you have given
this information and then you include a
set of most relevant documents answer
the following question and then you pass
the question and then you give that to
GPT and based on that it can generate a
comprehensive answer which is probably
going to be true and
the nice thing about this
that it can synthesize information from
many different documents so it's a bit
different from like what we've seen in
extractive QA for example and it's also
different because some companies might
want to have more this
conversational experience for their
searches and of course it sounds like a
human talking to you when you actually
have GPT generating answers and if
they're true even better
all right
um
I want to put this into practice now and
this is going to be a bit dense but I
hope
um
it will
not scare you off
Okay so
what we'll be building
is
a personal assisting assistant using
open ai's text DaVinci 3 Model so that's
3.5 and we'll be proceeding step by step
and we only give some code as a starter
just a few lines really and then we're
we're going to let the model build up
the whole system on its own
and I'm just going to walk you through
this I'm not going to run it actually
because I don't want to rely on the open
AI API right now and also answers are
non-deterministic so there might be a
few changes and we actually would have
to execute the code directly coming from
there so I don't want to debug here live
in front of you that would be way too
stressful
um so all right
then let's go
up first we initialize a prompt node
using the text DaVinci 3 model and as I
said that's our abstraction around a
large language model you also could swap
that for another model like gpt4 chat
GPT cohere or open source models
we are also using a prompt template you
can see that here
and the prompt template
it's pretty powerful and Haystack
because you can kind of enrich that
template with other information so you
can use a python F string like syntax in
the in the template to feed information
from other nodes that might be in the
pipeline into that template so that you
can then pass it to GPT in our case we
have a direct template I'm not adding
any information I just directly pass the
user instruction to GPT and then I
initialize our prompt node setting the
template giving it the open AI key
setting a max length and that's it
basically
okay next I want to give some initial
context to our model because if I now
ask it just to
generate code for me
you've seen that before it would make
things up and I actually want to have
working code so I'm going to give it
some initial context and what I'm giving
it here is
some just one page from our
documentation and that page is the
crawler documentation what does the
crawler do it allows you to scrape text
from websites and then using a so-called
indexing pipeline you can convert that
text into documents doing some
pre-processing and then store it in a
document store a document store might be
a vector database like a face document
store a quadrant document store but you
can also use something like
elasticsearch document store
which just has like yeah has both H3
bm25 so sparse and dance retrieval okay
so here's that crawler documentation
it's just a string it has a lot of code
examples in it because we believe that
developers need good documentation with
code examples and then the next thing
I'm doing here is I pass a list of URLs
as well and that lists are additional
documentation pages from Haystack
and then our first instruction is given
this documentation and I've given the
string write a crawler node that crawls
the following URLs and then I give it to
URLs and then I give it some
instructions on pre-processing as well
so it should index these documents in an
indexing Pipeline and it should split
full pages into 600 word chunks that
will make it easier for our retrieval
component
and as you can see here I'm actually
generating that code
and then what I want to do because it's
code coming from somewhere else I really
want to inspect that before running it
on my machine so I just have here the
markdown output of this generated code
and you can see it's instantiating a
document store it has my list of URLs it
has the right pre-processing so 600 word
splits and everything is just generated
and it looks pretty much correct and
when I go and execute that code it
actually runs so it's running and it
goes to these documentation Pages
scrapes the text indexes it into my
document store and I have more to work
with
all right
um
now is the second bit of code that I
wrote myself that's the retriever so I
just initialize a bm25 retriever so no
embeddings just very simple TF IDF like
search and then I give it one query how
to use the prompt node in a pipeline so
I want to build that system with a
prompt node and a pipeline that query
pipeline that I need for my personal
assistant and then our next natural
language instruction to the model is
using the snippet from the documentation
top result on how do I use the prompt
node in a pipeline
initialize a pipeline with the prompt
node and a prompt template and it should
like answer questions about technical
documentation and then I give it some
instructions say it should be GPT 3.5
turbo as a model that's chat GPT
and I tell it where it can find the API
key and stuff like that and then I
generated code again that's here so two
lines just the code generated
I inspect it again in markdown and you
can see it has a prompt template which
says answer the given question using the
provided context your answer should be
in the style of technical documentation
and should provide example code Snippets
if necessary format code AS markdown
python code and and then
here you can see that placeholder syntax
so joins the top result documents
basically together and then it passes
the question and then it should produce
an answer and then the rest of the code
looks perfect as well so initializes
another prompt node pipeline V2 this
time adds the nodes so it has the two
components a retrieval augmented
generation pipeline at the on the query
side has two components retrieval and
prompt node basically and a document
store but that's kind of baked into the
Retriever and when I execute that code I
can actually try it out afterwards so
now I have my system I have Knowledge
from the haystack documentation indexed
into a document store I have my query
pipeline set up and now I ask what is
Haystack Haystack is a python library
that provides a modular and extensible
interface for building end-to-end search
pipelines very good sounds totally
accurate and then I give it one more
question
um
so I ask how do I use the prompt node
with open source models because some of
you might ask that I don't want to use
openai I want to use open source and it
actually generates me a response using
flan T5 models they are open source and
it actually also generates these code
Snippets here as examples so that's
technical documentation for me that just
works perfectly
all right
and
I think that's that's it uh thanks for
listening uh you can
yeah thank you for this talk super
interesting and we got questions already
on slider perhaps also in the audience
I'll start with slider questions so
um could I use this ID with a local
running alpaca so um not GPT on remote
also just for security reasons or
something else
um
I think right now in the prompt node we
kind of limit
um some things to model that work that
we've tested that work really well and I
think at hacker doesn't work for some
things but it's very easy to integrate
you need to change a little thing and
then it's it should work and we're also
adding more and more models once we've
tested them and say like that's
something that works we added and I
think ipaka olama will be available soon
as well so cool and it's the Jupiter
notebook available in GitHub yeah I
guess it's okay on the link or it's
there yeah GitHub perfect
is there a question all in the audience
I can pass the microphone yes there
hi so what would you use like if you
want to support German as a language uh
with this
all the tragic stuff is in English the
examples how would you add translation
to whole model
um we do work with customers from
Germany
and we have one for example there
currently in a pilot for generative AI
pipeline all the data is in German and
GPT just works no need for translation
so it's it's a bit I'd say it's a bit
less grammatical sometimes so basically
the English variant never makes mistakes
German sometimes but it's very good
still
cool
but I don't know why it's not there my
question is why should I use Haystack
instead of the retrieval plugin of open
AI if I'm using open AI models I think
if you're if you're only using open AI
models and you just care for that
specific part of like retrieval
um and model you might use open AI but
probably
um you want to get the data somehow into
your document database I think that is
left to the user with open AI plugins
you need to handle that somehow you
might want to have pre-processing you
might want to use different models as
well compare a few for example and let's
say with Haystack your setup for the
future and don't have like you're not
locked into that open AI ecosystem
so one more question on slider can you
compare Haystack versus Lang chain
yeah definitely so I think most people
have heard about Lang chain it pretty
much does the same
when it comes to working with large
language models so a wrapper around the
most popular apis a few open source
models unified interface to query them I
think where Haystack differs is that
we've been around for some time and
actually the whole tooling for like
bringing these cool con Concepts to
production are
very well tested in Haystack so actually
looking at this okay end to end how do I
bring that to production now with all
the different components I think that's
just where we have a lot of experience
but they're very similar Frameworks so
I'd say try both out and see what you
like there was a question here
hi yeah thank you for the talk um I
wasn't quite able to find the Jupiter
on the GitHub page could you like click
yeah I think it's like it's like haste
it's it's like the only notebook in
there really because I thought it was
like 23
no there's I mean there's Haystack
tutorials but here in this repo there's
only like this
thank you
okay
and last question I think because the
time is short
um
what kind of speed up can you explain
that's an old one um
no I'm just a bit lost so sorry it's my
first third one is it expensive to use
Haystack in terms of tokens
uh Haystack is free look but if you call
open AI you have to pay for open AI
um
so what lies ahead in the haystack
roadmap
um So currently we're working on a few
things we've built out our agent support
and we want to bid that out more so
language models acting even more
autonomous autonomously but then we also
want to focus more on really
streamlining that end-to-end deployment
experience having like updating our rest
API a little bit and then soon this year
definitely we'll be looking at Haystack
2.0 where we want to make our pipelines
even better and more flexible and faster
easier to maintain yeah
so thank you the time is over there are
a lot of questions on slider which
remain but I think you're still here and
perhaps you can also look in slide and
answer them so thank you very much for
your talk I think it's another Applause
yeah